what's up everyone welcome to Chicago
I'm your host down Saucon you know me
I'm currently here crewing for Tony
Robbins out unleash the power within
also hanging out with some friends doing
some interviews you know doing the cool
stuff in shot town in the summer and
it's nice here in the summer six months
of freezing cold temperatures in the
winter not my fav but here we are having
a good time and I really have had a lot
of thoughts on my mind and one of the
most pressing ones is time and I know
that time can be something that kind of
slips moment to moment to moment and
it's so fascinating thinking about how
much time we have until we die and what
does that mean it means that every
second that we have is one of great
importance each and every single one of
these moments because it's a second
clicking ticking towards death each one
but it's also a moment of ability to be
inspired or to have some sort of a
desire to bring some sort of good to the
world it's a moment to potentially fall
in love or a moment to make the earth a
better place make society better
so these moments are great it's a moment
to eat some food a moment to breathe
some fresh air
a moment to just think and ponder so
times so fascinating because it's so
limited and I'm writing about time a lot
right now and will release a book very
soon on this and we'll make it a series
as well on video and trying to make
really relatable graphics to explain
this but the importance of time
especially for people that are young
that the more that you learn about the
world that you're in at a younger age
when your brain is forming the better it
is for you and furthermore if you take
what you learn and then you compound it
over time to become smarter and more
impactful in the world that just helps
you so much more so it's almost our
obligation as parents I'm not one yet if
I will be but it's almost a parental
obligation to ensure that the child
realizes that time is such a precious
resource for them and to every decision
matters when you log on to the internet
with the spare moment are you going to
learn or are you going to distract
yourself and what are the consequences
of doing those things now this further
is very important because our rock is so
small earth is so small it only takes 40
days to sail around earth it's a very
very small rock and global leadership so
important so the more kids that we have
focused on figuring out how to make the
world a better place
the further we'll be able to get as a
society so it's up to us parents
communities groups of people teachers to
inspire kids to realize this and the
faster that they do this and the faster
that we implement these skills into them
and they implement them into themselves
that the more impactful they'll be so
global leadership so important here how
do we progress moving forward and make
sure that there's not some sort of a
malevolence that takes over but rather
benevolence
so another thought about time is that
this is becoming especially important as
you birth children into the world to
have your children be focused on things
with their time that enable them for
long periods of time to be
ready for the information technology and
exponential technology explosion that
we're currently in right now so if your
child's focused on skills that are going
to be automated that's really bad for
you it's really more important for the
kid to be focused on skills that are not
going to be automated for very long
periods of time so what can the child
learn in order to make themselves most
useful of greatest utility to
civilization this is a very important
question that we don't frequently talk
about our answer so this has been some
thoughts on time a little bit about the
neural infrastructure of the child's
mind a little bit about global
leadership and a little bit about
exponential technology and kind of what
humanity's facing so we got to really
figure things out here I have a lot of
foresight I don't treat this as fear
whatsoever this is only foresight and
[Music]
I'm out here in Shaa town it's been
great seeing Robins and Robins crew the
village is massive that puts on this
event it's like five hundred people that
put on the event for 10,000 people and
that just gives me even more insight
into what's gonna have to happen in
order for the whole sport stadiums for
our vision of sports stadiums for
full-day multidisciplinary events
featuring global leaders and curious
intellectuals that are wanting to get
inspired into thinking and doing and
building and creating that it's gonna
take a massive village of people so we
need you we need you to make that vision
come true by 2019 we're gonna get there
so it's very inspirational to be part of
everybody's breakthroughs that are going
on right now shy towns beautiful during
the summer as you can see behind me it's
amazing and Lake Michigan's right there
the water that you see behind me as well
it's like Michigan this is Lakeshore
Drive there's a bunch of nice nice boats
here as well it's just very peaceful
minutes in the middle
of the night there's no traffic which is
what I love I hate driving with traffic
I'm very exciting to eliminate traffic
from our lives I've done a video on that
before but we got a big goal ahead of us
and I'm very grateful to be surrounded
by smart people be doing some interviews
here spending some time with some really
close family friends and I'll be back in
San Francisco conducting more interviews
and building the future and writing
about time and making videos about time
so I appreciate everybody tuning in to
hear about time if you guys had a good
time if the content to share with some
other people talk about time inspire
other people to care about time join us
in the movement join us on YouTube on
simulation series join us on patreon the
simulation series and help us help us
join the team we've got a lot of cool
positions open and we're gonna build the
future together there's no hierarchy
this is just a collective effort it's a
collective effort erase our names from
it when it's done but if we can inspire
millions of people around the world to
build the future and to care more about
time and disseminating this wisdom to
more people we've done our damn jobs
it's a beautiful world and you're
beautiful thanks for tuning in much love
talk to you soon peace